là où ça bouge ici au zénith de
conneries doit alors doit-on stage avec
nous mais c'est moi qui vais présenter
ce spectacle un spectacle formidable
ah non non non non non c'est moi qui
vais présenter les spectacles de pégase
et icare ici nommé génique de brega on
avait dit que c'est non non non non non
non avec bertrand
oui on a dit que c'était lui qui s'en
occupe et c'est quoi ce cirque cyrus
comment le spectacle se déroule ici au
zénith de caen
ça fait près de 25 ans que ne tourne
plus loin et on a décidé en 2016 de
reprendre un petit peu la route n'est
pas comme d'habitude pas comme le
faisait mon père ou mon grand-père ou
même mon arrière grand père parce que
chez nous ça date de plus 1854 et donc
on a décidé pour mes enfants pour mes
petits-enfants il faut toute l'équipe
qui travaille avec moi à paris est bien
de leur montrer qu'on pouvait faire
exporter ce spectacle dans une salle
magnifique et celle du zénith de caen
existe
seront présents m de diamètre a été
importé en 1774 par une aiguille anglais
des s'appelait philippe asselin et ils
en sortent et seront de 13 mètres de
diamètre en plein coeur de paris rue du
faubourg du temple et le pin il ya
toujours eu dans le siècle en tous les
cas un peu plus de 150 ans seront de 13
mètres de diamètre et si au zénith de
caen
eh bien on va y déposer 40 mètres cubes
de terre végétale
je prends les deux thèmes du spectacle
ces deux thèmes importants de la
mythologie grecque
c'est pégase et il car tu peu nerveux
des deux personnages
sans direction ça peut dire quelque
chose pegas c'est le cheval et ligne il
était réputé indomptables il était
indomptables et l'homme a réussi à
l'éviter moi je dis pas vrai c'est jeudi
éduqués et puis ensuite l'homme
un autre petit qui avait à peu près
tournage et s'applique à et son papa du
dal il ya donné des ailes en lui disant
avec ça on va te distinguer de tous les
autres espèces vivant sur la terre
ik il s'est brûlé les ailes parce que
c'est un peu trop rapprochée du soleil
et nous comme on le sait enfin pas du
groupe
là on se bouge donc au zénith de caen
vous l'avez compris c'est un spectacle
qui a lieu samedi et dimanche
une grosse machine formidable faut
vraiment venir voir ce spectacle
remercier infiniment d'avoir répondu aux
questions surtout d'avoir permis à
edouard de faire ses premiers pas dans
le journalisme il a de l'avenir
moi je crois aussi
spleen anciens est en concert samedi au
théâtre de la haute ville à granville et
le lendemain à la fermeture éclair de
caen
et demain dans là où ça bouge nous
parlerons de vera c'est la nouvelle
pièce de la comédie de caen mise en
scène par marcial di fonzo bo avec comme
actrice principale
karin viard ils seront douze invités
demain soir dans la seconde